我朋友們好,我是三陽
歡迎來到這個帶你用交易前生險的頻道
海歸交易法
有在做交易的人對這個策略都不陌生
最原始的海歸交易法策略
是利用一個叫唐齊安通道
Don't Train Channel 的指標
利用通道的高低點去做突破策略
在1983年就已經讓這套策略的創始團隊
有了平均100%的年化收益
但實際用過海歸的人都知道
通道突破交易最讓人頭痛的
就是低於40%的平均勝率
以及30%以上的基本資金回撤
市場沒有趨勢的時候
就是不斷的虧損
那麼我封面說的200次交易
90倍的數據是怎麼來的呢?
僅僅使用一個唐前通道指標
能夠做到這樣的獲利嗎?
答案是
能
但你要反著做
你不該做突破
而是做回調
我會在這部影片裡告訴夥伴們
這個回調交易法的進租場方式
以及該如何選擇適合的商品
如果你想知道怎麼用這個方法填滿自己的荷包
絕對不要錯過今天這部影片
螳旗安通道的計算方法是
它會根據當前K線往回推
去捕捉某個特定騎速內所有K棒的最高最低點
並且利用得到的高低點去畫通道
原始的螳旗安通道策略非常簡單
定義出兩個不同騎速的通道
大騎速通道的上下軌作為突破的進場騎點
小騎速通道的上下軌作為倉位的退出點
而我們都知道次長有70%是處於震盪期
在震盪期的時候
原始的海龜策略回測幅度大
而且勝率低
那如果我們把思路反過來
利用唐其安通道去做回調的進場
會怎麼樣呢?
於是我利用了一週的時間
快速學了一下TradingView的潘雨法
成功實現了唐其安通道的回調做法
我會把自己寫的唐其安通道改良指標
免費開源分享給大家
並且讓夥伴們知道這個策略進出場的方式
他們全部都是客觀條件判斷完全不會有任何主觀或模能兩可的空間即使是新手也能輕鬆學會在進入策略解析之前還是要提醒一下夥伴們我的頻道是專門分享金融交易的知識與工具
以及如何把交易自動化的程式教學
如果你需要這方面的免費資訊
記得訂閱我的頻道
然後打開小鈴鐺
這樣你就不會錯過所有能幫助你用錢生錢的致富方法
首先各位夥伴們
幫我把留言區置頂的代碼複製下來
打開TradingView的商品行情頁面
這裡我是以币安的比特幣起貨1分鐘作為例子
移到下方視窗的PiMid編輯器
把我提供的代碼整個複製貼上
記得要把它儲存下來
然後點選新增道圖表
接下來我們調整指標的設置
首先我們把期數定為23期
然後樣式的部分
我們先把上軌中線
以及下軌中線兩條黃線拿掉
這兩條線在這次的策略裡不會用到
下一集我們再解釋這兩條線的用法
不想錯過了夥伴
記得點擊訂閱按鈕
到這裡指標設定就完成了
那我們該如何尋找進場訊號呢?
我們分成兩個部分去觀察
也就是高低點相對狀態與進場K棒組合
當前高低點的相對狀態怎麼找呢?
多單交易的時候
我們要尋找最近一次碰到綠線上軌的高點K線
以圖內這條藍線來說
在藍線之前最近一次的高點
是我們去定義LUN的起點K線
接下來我們從這個高點往回找
找到低點後再找下一個高點
以此類推直到找出兩個高點及一個低點為止
如果第一點高於第三點
我們就定義為多頭突破成功
開始尋找進場的K棒訊號
如果後續出現了兩根K棒的組合
是像圖內的圈圈這樣子的特徵
右邊K棒的收盤架必須滿足的條件是
大於左邊K棒的高點
小於上軌白線
且大於開盤架同時右邊K棒的開盤架要小於綠線中軌兩根K棒的最低點小於下軌白線並且最重要的是這一段的回調不能碰到綠線下軌
碰到下軌後的做法
我們下一集會講
都滿足以上條件的話
我們就在該K棒結束後進場
止損點為該兩根K棒的最低點
止盈點選擇本一比1比2的位置
可以看到這一單是順利止盈出場的
空單一樣分成兩部分觀察
要選擇空投浪突破成功的形態
去尋找进场K棒
右边K棒的收盘价必须满足
小于左边K棒的低点
大于下轨白线
且小于开盘价三个要素
右边K棒的开盘价要大于绿线中轨
两根K棒的最高点要大于上轨白线
并且这次的回调
不能碰到绿线上轨
止损点为该两根K棒的最高点
止盈点选择本1比1比2的位置
到达止盈的时候可以马上出场
也可以等K棒确定收盘超过止盈点再出场
要注意的是
因为我们做的是回调单
不论多空方向
只要价格触碰到了唐旗安通道
反向了上下轨
就视为该次回调入场失败
也就是说
多单仓位进场后
碰到了下轨
就把多单仓位退出
空单仓位进场后
碰到了上轨
就把空单仓位退出
那么这套方法回测表现如何呢
我挑出了两个加密货币商品
以及一个外汇商品
来做回测与最佳化
首先是开头提到的
币安BTC起货合约
使用了刚刚讲解的交易规则
并且用1%的资金亏损风险
以及100美金的初始资金进行回撤
并且回撤中不做任何加码动作
日期范围为今年7月31到8月22号
可以看到策略在23天内进行了229次交易
报酬率来到了惊人的11倍
资金回撤幅度竟然只有13%
远低于一般唐旗安突破策略的资金回撤量
接下来我把商品换成了BinX交易所的ATOM期货合约回撤日期为8月7号到8月22號再把通道期數調整成27並且下調止盈為1.75倍後在257次交易中也獲得了4倍多的收益
可以看得出這個策略對於
加密貨幣的1分鐘時區K棒
是影響相當高
那麼在較大一級的時區中
這個策略能在外匯中獲利嗎?
我選擇了ONDA經濟商的歐元對銀棒來測試
時區改為了5分鐘
回測日期為5月15到8月22號
通道為22期
327次的交易只讓帳戶翻了1倍
並且這是交易條件有調整的狀況下
可以看得出兩期內K棒的高低點
在外匯商品中無法反映出最好的止损狀態
如果把每個餐位的風險提高到2%
會有什麼樣的表現呢?
歐元對英棒的表現平平
ATOM的獲利變成了22倍
但最大回撤也跟一般的海龜交易法一樣
超過30%了
最讓人掉下巴的莫過於BTC起貨合約
50%左右的勝率
1 4分之1的資金回撤
獲利來到了驚人的91倍
如果夥伴們也覺得這個方法有利可圖
請記得影片裡的商品只是舉例
不代表任何投資的方向建議
我開發的這個策略是回調單
所以商品的選擇上
必須要是常發生回調
或震盪前進的
通道其速的選擇區間
會落在20-23附近
並且任何商品在使用這個策略之前
建議都先進行500-1000次以上的長期測試
而我自己認為它是相當有發展潛力的
剛剛的91倍是啥意思啊
就是在這23天內你的1萬元變成了91萬元啦
不說了夥伴們
我要趕快來轉戰加密貨幣了
如果你們有關於這個策略的疑問或任何想法
歡迎在底下留言
或者你們有想測試的商品參數也可以直接留言上來
搞不好下一個獲利滿滿的就是你選的商品
下一期會更新行情觸碰到上下軌之後的逆勢做法
有興趣的夥伴們別忘了點讚訂閱我哦
那我們下一期見